der gast steht hier immer im mittelpunkt
und das ist wichtig dass die leute zudem
zum gast anfangen offen und freundlich
sind es kommt natürlich auch sehr sehr
viel fachwissen noch dazu über das essen
muss man bescheid wissen das heißt wenn
die teller am pass stehen in der küche
muss man direkt sehen was es ist also
man muss verschiedene fleischsorten
kennen verschiedene gemüsesorten kennen
man muss sich mit wein auskennen muss
nachher wissen welcher wein passt zu
welchem essen weil das gehört auch dazu
dass man die gäste berät also es kommt
auch noch sehr sehr viel an fachkenntnis
nun gerade im bereich essen und trinken
aber auch wichtig ist die kommunikation
im team
sowas muss jemand der hier arbeitet
natürlich auch können wenn man noch gar
keine erfahrung hat kann man
gucken ob irgendwo einen aushilfsjob
meinetwegen angeboten wird wo man dann
an gelernt wird nur dann wird man
gelernt hat dass fast in dem restaurant
gebraucht wird und wenn man sich dann
dazu entscheidet eine ausbildung zu
machen
dann ja dann geht haltlos gestern die
berufsschule mit dabei um die ganzen
theoretischen sachen zu lernen und die
praxis lernt man dann im betrieb wichtig
ist halt dass man den betrieb findet der
zu einem passt und dass man dann auch in
den betrieb von zu den kollegen und tina
einzige nachteil dass die arbeitszeit
dass man halt viel am wochenende
arbeiten muss und auch viel abend
arbeiten muss also wenn
geburtstagsfeiern sind dass man auch mal
keine zeit hat um dahin zu gehen
die vorteile sind dass wirklich jeder
tag anders ist dass man
sehr viel abwechslung hat in dem buch
also man macht zwar jeden tag das
gleiche aber dadurch dass jeden tag
andere gäste da sind manchmal hat man
zähne tisch manchmal mein geburtstag
manchmal eine hochzeit also ist wirklich
jeder tag läuft komplett anders und das
macht halt super spaß die gäste sind
normalerweise echt nett und was auch
richtig viel spaß macht es wenn die
gäste mit schlechter laune kommen und
mit guter laune wieder gehen